Now, today we were planning on
doing one of our Voter Voices
segments, uh, but instead,
I'd like to take a moment
to assure everyone
that killer clowns are not real.
They are a manifestation
of our anxiety.
People are super freaked out
by the election.
Some goobers are taking
that anxiety
and they're just bringing it
into the real world.
They're trolling us all.
And in a way, aren't they kind
of holding up a mirror
to society and reflecting
where we're at right now?
This sort of grotesque,
painted figure
that's darker than it seems
beneath the surface.
But I promise you, there is no
such thing as a murder clown.
Yes, there is!
Jesus (bleep) Christ!
(evil laugh)
Hello!
(laughing):
I'm Giggles the Murder Clown.
(evil laugh)
Giggles.
You're real? What the...?
Ooh, yes, I'm real, Chris.
And boy, oh, boy,
do I love murder.
(horn toots)
(applause)
(snickers)
First of all,
I think white face is wrong.
-And...
-(laughter)
You're, you're not
gonna kill us, are you?
Probably not. Uh-uh.
Hey... you want to smell
my flower?
No.
It's full of human blood.
All right.
Oh! That's...
(laughing):
Giggles.
Why... Why are you here?
Oh, Chris, because this election
is very important.
And I just want to make sure
our voices are heard.
Now I'm not here only on behalf
of murder clowns, okay?
I'm also here for thieving
magicians, loitering acrobats,
jugglers that are cannibalistic,
and Scientologists.
(applause)
HARDWICK:
Okay.
Yeah.
Hey, hey.
If you don't vote,
you don't count.
Okay, so I assume, because
you're a violent psychopath
trying to sow chaos,
you're voting for Trump.
Oh, no way, man.
He scares the (bleep) out of me.
-Seriously?
-Yeah, yeah.
Look, Chris, look.
The-the paint on my face may be
rendered from the human fat
and kidney blood of my victims,
but I'm not crazy.
No, no, no, no.
I am with her!
All right, uh...
Yeah.
I mean...
That's why we're popping up
everywhere lately--
-to get out the vote.
-Oh.
Just look at this map
of clowns being seen
from Atlas Obscura, huh?
We got Florida, Ohio,
Pennsylvania,
swing states, huh?
But also, we clowns
feel comfortable there
because they remind us of hell.
Well, okay, okay, this is
shedding a lot of light on this.
So, the murder clown thing
is all about voting,
but why are you
luring kids into the woods?
Oh, boy, it's called
grassroots campaigning, Chris.
You lure a kid into the woods,
tie them up,
wave around a chain saw,
boom-- another vote for Hillary.
-Wh... I don't...
-Yeah!
No, hang on, though--
what about this footage
of a clown
going up to some random person's
door, brandishing a machete?
Okay, door-to-door
canvassing, Chris.
Come on.
You knock on the door,
you break in, you hide
in the attic for 15 years,
coming out only at night,
staring over the children
while they sleep
and breathing in their breath,
boom-- another vote for Hillary.
Okay.
-(horn honking)
-I get it, okay, I get it.
-(laughs)
-So, then I guess this footage
of a clown chasing joggers
through a park
was just about
getting them to vote?
Oh, no, actually, we murdered
the (bleep) out of those guys.
-Oh.
-Yeah, yeah.
But the point is
everyone needs
to get out there and vote.
Hey, as scary as we are,
we are nowhere near as bad
as Donald Trump, okay?
-(whooping, cheering)
-Thank you, thank you.
I never... I never, ever...
I never thought I,
a murder clown,
would be saying this,
but please don't vote
for the psychopath
who has fake hair
and an orange face. Please!
-Please! -All right,
Giggles the Clown, everyone.
Voter Voices. These are people
from your community.
-It...
-(echoing): (Giggles laughs)
Where the (bleep) did she go?